Trailer "JUSTICE LEAGUE"
There is a stranger, who comes to this
village from the sea.
He comes in the winter when people are
hungry, and brings fish. He comes on the king tide.
That was last night.
Talk.
I believe that an enemy is coming
from far away
I'm looking for warriors.
This stranger.
Others like him.
I'm building an alliance to defend us. It's
very important that I see this man.
Barry Allen, Bruce Wayne. You said that like it
explains why there is a total stranger
sitting in the dark in my second
favorite chair.
He said he'll fight with us? More or less.
More more or more less?
*thump*
*ugh*
Probably more or less. He said no. He said no.
Look man, I dont know who you are, but whoever you're looking for
So you're fast..
That feels like an oversimplification. I'm putting together a team.
People with special abilities.
See I believe enemies are coming. Stop right there. I'm in.
You are? Just like that?
Yeah, I uhh...
I need friends.
Great.
Can I keep this?
I heard about you, didn't think you were real.
I'm real when it's useful
Arthur Curry..
I hear you can talk to fish.
hey youtubers it's Charlie they totally
brought Justice League footage I was so
surprised
it gives you a really good idea for the
humor of the film so let's break it down
this is so great so you can see the
aesthetic is a lot different from the
Wonder Woman movie you know each of the
characters has their own identity so
when they get there solo films like the
Flash movie for instance it will be much
more in the tone of Barry Allen that you
see in this in the tone you see these
Justice League film so like you have
this really grimy look like the world is
in this really dark place like he's up
in this fishing village trying to get
Aquaman in the beginning of the trailer
but then as they move through the rest
of the clip things brighten up a little
bit like the tone picks up the music
kicks in
is like a really fun take on the classic
idea of putting the band together which
is the whole reason for sidelining
Superman look at the end of Batman V
Superman they give you this teaser like
you know that he's going to be in
Justice League but they really wanted
Batman to have the job of putting the
team together so that it wasn't just
like a god showing up saying
follow me I'm this amazing god so like
he has that funny comment with Wonder
Woman where she's like is you know more
or less is he on the team is going to
be fighting us with what's going on in
that means like yeah he's probably be
fighting us quite a bit then Aquaman
body slammed him against the wall so you
get an idea for the tone of each of the
characters but I kind of mentioned it in
my Wonder Woman video James one was on
stage at comic-con and he's a great
horror film director and he's bringing a
lot of the energy to Aquaman like the
actual environment that Aquaman lives in
is very terrified like when you go down
that deep their big sea monsters
so I think that Aquaman is gonna be like
DC's version of a really awesome horror
film but it will also be contrasted with
the Majesty with the glory of Atlantis
but we finally get an actual look at the
flash costume so as you can see it's
apple red is not like the maroon of
grant gustin's costume
it's much more take based it looks more
like armor than actual suit you would
walk around in his lightning is what it
looks a little more like traditional
lightning than the stylized version you
see on the TV show with like the
different colors of Speed Force
Lightning his lair here is hilarious I
love the set design is a good metaphor
for his mind but you know because he's
the flash
he can process information really fast
he comes off like a complete
scatterbrain
even though internally he's actually
processing things like a normal person
would
it's just that to other people he seems
like a complete scatterbrain just
because he can't slow down
so this is probably my favorite scene in
the trailer here it's you know it's very
Robert Downey jr. spider-man
civil war scene where barri walks in and
just sees Bruce sitting there like a hey
what's up
random dude what are you doing in here
he doesn't know that he's Batman tell
Bruce throws the battering at him
it goes into slow motion you see like
the little light bulb appear above his
head and he's like oh my god this dude
is Batman
so it gives you a good sense for Barry
Allen's personality in contrast with
Aquaman like Aquaman is like you want me
to be on your team like body slams
Batman the flash on the other side of
that totally says yes before Batman can
even get through his sentence like I'm
putting a team to any just like stopped
some i'm totally in
I'm down please be my friend so just
completely adorable
Geoff Johns said something really cool
about the flash - is that because he
moves so fast
everyone else is standing still by
comparison he's very lonely he lives in
a world by himself but they haven't
really explained in the comics of the TV
show very well because he liked he runs
around with the communicator in his ear
so he does here people at STAR Labs
talking to him but under normal
circumstances when the flash is moving
at super speed
sound waves don't travel to him so he
can't hear anything so it's almost like
he's traveling around in the silent
world with a bunch of mannequins just
standing still so he's very lonely and
it definitely does not help that he's a
metahuman and as we've seen in this
world so far
metahumans aren't the most popular
people Lex Luthor has been researching
them so it looks like the world is
slowly getting ready to learn about all
them because the other big thing here
they tease the mother box so you see
like these Viking looking people bearing
in the ground
this is obviously at the end of the
first dark side war i mentioned this in
a couple of their videos but they say in
the ancient history of the world
the Atlanteans and amazon in another
ancient one fought off dark side
a long long time ago three mother boxes
were left behind and that's what we saw
in that deleted scene from Batman V
Superman
they've also confirmed that Steppenwolf
is going to be the villain of this first
Justice League film so we're probably
not going to see dark side like will see
shades of him in the movie but he won't
actually be the big villain for a while
i was just too powerful for you to roll
him out right away
so let me know what you guys think about
the footage in the aesthetic of this
like you definitely get the sense that
there's a lot more humor in this film I
think they found a nicer balance between
the real and serious tone of the
universe the circumstances that they're
in they're very dire circumstances but
they also let Batman be funny like he's
a very funny person
Batman
is a great sense of humor but it is very
different from say like Barry Allen
sense of humor so expect to see more of
that the next time they post a big
trailer
it's probably be a while before they
post it but they've been shooting
justice league so I would expect like
the next really big justice league
trailer
whenever they start to market wonder
woman in the spring so get justice
league type it's gonna be awesome
they haven't really explained how
Superman is coming back i'm expecting
him to show up relatively late in the
Justice League film because the first
part of the film is Bruce putting the
team together then recognizing the
threat probably getting their asses
handed to them by Steppenwolf then you
know Superman probably shows up third
act that is at least what I'm expecting
but just a reminder there's a new round
of the giveaway going on now all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video is
just a twenty-dollar amazon gift card so
because there's so many other videos
that are dropping today my next video
will probably be the flash season 3
trailer that will post in a couple hours
so there will be a lot of other videos
that will just post tomorrow so anything
I don't get to today I will totally post
tomorrow so no worries
well you guys wait for that video to
post you can click here for my wonder
woman trailer breakdown and you can
click here for all my other comic con
videos
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight.